[Music]
this
is star talk cosmic queries edition
i got chuck nice my co-host jeff hey
neil what's happening
chuck this is a grab bag it is indeed we
used to call it
the cosmic potpourri we used to call it
cosmic gumbo which was my favorite
galactic
not cosmic galactic galactic combo
and uh but now we have a grab back which
i it makes me wonder where does that
come from grab back you know it means
just like
an assortment of pretty much
miscellaneous items yeah yes the
presence that
in the holiday season where you reach in
and grab and you don't know what you're
getting
is that really what it is from santa
claus why wouldn't it be okay
cool yeah yeah we called that christmas
you've been in my office i have a grab
bag in there that's a black hole
right right
it is it says black hole and so you know
it's a black hole it says it
very nice very cool that reminds me of
uh
completely off topic but the discoverer
of pluto
his name is clyde tombaugh my boy lived
into his deep into his 90s
right and because he wasn't letting go
of pluto any sooner than he was he was
hoping that he was hoping that it would
happen
he was he was trying to keep it yeah on
his deathbed they told him
you did it it's a planet and he was just
like oh thank god
and why'd you lie to him he's dying he's
dead
he's dead what do you mean why did i lie
to that's like somebody's dying and you
say to him
you know i never loved you a long time
to report that information exactly
it's like he's dead like let him you
know i loved you so dearly my entire
life i shall miss you
and then they die you're like oh thank
god
so he so he was asked how did you
how what did it take to discover pluto
you know
how hard was that and he said well when
i got the photos of the night sky it was
really easy
because there was an arrow pointing to
it oh that's hilarious
because every picture you've ever seen
in pluto there is an arrow
that's funny so there you go
all right so let's do this grab that
yeah anything under the sun and above it
as well there you go
let's go for it oh okay now that makes
me think the first
question well just to remind people
these are all from patreon
yes members yeah and if you uh if you
would like uh please go to patreon.com
radio support us and uh our
our lower level no i should that's the
wrong way to say that entry level our
entry level thank you neil our entry
level um
members uh you get to ask neil a
question on our
and the reason we did that one is
because patreon is a great way for us to
experiment and try things because you're
supporting us financially
but more importantly we were getting
like
15 000 people asking questions
and so this is a great way to cull it
down so we're not asking you to pay for
your questions
but in return for your gracious support
you know we ask
questions which sounds like they're
paying for the question but all right
see and i knew you were gonna do that no
i tried to mpr this neil
i tried to you did all right you were
empty you were smelling
npr the whole way okay
you pulled a chuckle on me you were like
yeah and we are paying for it
i should hang around you for so long oh
my goodness
all right here we go this is david brian
smith and he says um
uh yes this is really my name not just
made up so actually you can pronounce it
chuck
oh you jerk i should read these in
advance
all right david you got me um he says
uh can you explain the moon's
wobble and how it affects the earth
interesting okay
well so i don't think he's referring
to the moon's wobble because that's not
interesting
what's interesting there's something
called a libration
not libation not libation is that is it
anything like
a liger no
okay a libration a libration
right you mean liger like the cross
between a lion and a tiger yeah you ever
see those things they're kids yeah yeah
no that's not this has nothing to do
with that chuck
i just heard lie okay a libration so
what's happening is
the moon's orbit again i'm assuming
that's what he's referring to because
the moon doesn't have a wobble that
anyone cares about
so that's what but there's an
interesting light vibration
so what's happening is because the
moon's orbit
around the earth is not a perfect circle
okay it's an ellipse
i can get as close as 225
000 or so miles and as far as almost 250
000 miles
there's a 25 000 mile range between when
it's closest and when it's farthest
okay the moon is also tidally locked
to earth so it's always showing the same
face okay that's that's a natural
phenomenon in the universe and systems
of orbiting objects
naturally descend into that state
relative to each other so that's fine
no nothing weird going on there here's
the problem
okay if it were a perfectly circular
orbit you would only ever see exactly
the same side
and it's locked you'd only ever see
exactly the same side
towards you okay here's the problem when
your orbit is not circular
when it's elliptical you are moving
faster
in your orbit when you're closer and
slower in your orbit when you're farther
away
okay so the point is
if you are tidally locked and in a
perfectly circular orbit for every
little bit around the earth you
revolve you will rotate a little bit
always keeping that
same face pointed so everything
works out but if you're going a little
faster than average or a little
slower than average that little bit that
you rotate doesn't line up
as it would if you were in a perfectly
circular orbit it lines up on average
but if you're if you're sort of fast in
your orbit
then that little bit that you turn
doesn't quite compensate
for how far you've gone around the earth
and if you're slow in your orbit
you haven't quite turned enough right
so when you
look at time-lapse photos of the moon
it is it is striking to behold the moon
is like
it's it's it's like turning a little to
the left to you a little to the right
so we can see more than 50 of its
surface
over the duration of a moon okay
yeah a mouth i like that better it's the
month on them what's the original word
of course
so yeah well so go ahead yeah yeah
so and yes to the extent that there's a
wobble and anybody cares about it
um that's true anytime you have a
rotating object
where it's not perfectly spherical if
there's a
slight bit of mass off to the side then
there are extra torques on it
and that'll sort of bob as it turns we
wobble on our axis uh because of
forces that are tugging on us like such
as the moon
as we rotate and as we go around the sun
so you do get this sort of wobbling and
bobbing
but for me the most the fun thing is the
libration if you
just google vibration of the moon and
look at the time-lapse video
it's it's it's it's striking because you
don't get to see it
that way because we see the moon once a
night you know or once a day and when
you
time-lapse it for a month so it's it's
kind of like the face that it shows us
just turns a little bit yeah exactly
actually i should thank you that's way
easier yeah that's what i should have
done it got a little to the left
right right so it's like when it when
it's 25 000 miles out it's like letigray
and when it's like right close to us
it's like blue steel
so
and i even know what blue steel means
that's embarrassing
okay not really that's that's not really
embarrassing
you were in the movie i was in zoolander
too that's right
that's right and i did do a blue steel
imitation
i did in fact it's the very final thing
you see
in the movie i am the last
thing you see in the movie zoom lighter
too and anyone listening
please go look at that no no
please don't look please go look at that
because i believe you're wearing a fur
coat too which is nice
it's it's a it's a it's a shoulder wrap
for it's not i don't think it's a full
coat i think it was just something
around like around
there's a neck yeah like a like uh they
call that a stole back in the store it
was a
right right and then i sort of turn my
head and then i make give the expression
just to be clear chuck yeah okay okay
i've been in
four movie franchises
okay and for three of them
there were no more movies made after
well i was
advancing that's pretty damn hilarious
okay
so i i was in uh i was in
ice age five okay
and the critics said it's about time the
series went extinct like all the
creatures
oh damn oh my god i thought it was a
pretty good
movie though because because it had a
lot of science in it so i was science
bias that's why i was one of the
characters
so that was the last of the ice ages i
was in
shark nato six okay
you didn't know there were five others
dude well i did not number one
okay and i'm so glad to hear that
there's not a sharknado seven
[Laughter]
i'm just saying so unlike the fast and
the furious
uh could you please be in that please be
in that no but i don't want to kill the
franchise i do and that's why
that's why
exactly i just want the last scene to be
you like cruising like yo what up
[Music]
keep looking up but not while you're
driving not while you're driving
all right give me another question okay
here we go uh
zach metcalf wants to know this uh good
morning gentlemen
uh have anatomically modern human beings
always lived
under the same night sky have the stars
had
time to migrate and rearrange themselves
in approximately 150
000 years that we've been looking
up love that question so first of all
the dude knows that however fixed the
stars look like they are on the night
sky
in fact they are moving through space
and
obviously the farther away something is
the less from day to day you're going to
notice that it's moving
right so that's that's true on earth
as well this is what led to the old
childhood
concept where you say mommy daddy why
is the moon following me right as you
walk down the street
because the trees go by and the
buildings go by and the moon is just
there
well if you kept walking for a million
more miles you would leave the moon far
behind
so you're just not walking far enough
for something that distant
to reveal the fact that you're walking
past it
so the farther away something is the
less obvious its motion
is to you okay so the
uh so we have all the stars in the night
sky and they are
part of the solar neighborhood how's
that for a friendly
phrase that we use
you're now the mr rogers of the cosmos
[Laughter]
welcome to the neighborhood yes hello
neighbor
oh you're about to explode as a
supernova oh let me get the hell out of
the neighborhood
okay that would be an interesting
excellent
so we're all orbiting sort of the center
of the galaxy together but even
with that sort of community movement
there's movement
among us okay right so if you go back
75 000 years we were anatomically human
i think that's
sort of early homo sapien 100 000 years
ago
you would not recognize most of the
constellations of the night sky
what that's right that's right oh man
well not most i would say about half the
nearby
the stars that are nearby us that trace
out the constellations
they'd be in a completely different
place so for example the big dipper
which we know of is looking like in the
in uh where is it in england
is it called the uh the big saucepan
the biggest
right the little dipper the handle bends
the other way like a ladle okay
okay and the big point is all the stars
of the big dipper
believe it or not are part of a coherent
star cluster
which just really close so you'll think
of them as a tight cluster
but so they're all sort of together and
they're moving in their own
sort of orbits and the big dipper would
get flattened out it turns out
we've done the math on this wow you just
wouldn't recognize it as a big dipper at
all
okay go on terracina no last name
like share just terracina
and tara cena says hey neil hey chuck
why is mercury
the element okay very nice clarification
there teresina
uh she's talking about astrophysicists
she gotta where she
got to make that clarification yes she
says why is mercury the element
liquid the elements before and after it
in the periodic table
gold and thalamum thalium are
both solid at ambient temperature so why
does one proton make such
a difference oh i love that question
because i have no idea why
well well i'll get to that question when
we return after our first break on star
talk
cosmic queries chuck we're back cosmic
queries
okay grab bag grab the questions coming
from everywhere
yep that's right kind of left field
right field behind home plate
that's that's when you know a fan is mad
oh if it comes from behind if it comes
from behind
no if they float your head then they're
magical exactly
so this last question was from
tattersina well who was this
yep terracino who says hey neil chuck
why
is there why is mercury the element
liquid the elements before and after in
the periodic table
are both solid at ambient temperature so
why does
one proton make such a difference okay i
i
i can answer that um i don't have a
good idea i don't know
wow okay well i mean i can fumble
through an
answer okay i will give you an answer
but it will be wholly unsatisfying
because i don't have a deep
understanding of it but i can give you
an answer and here it is you ready
all right okay because i said so
[Music]
because it's nature thank you chuck
next question that clear it up for you
it's nature
crystal clear there you go all right go
ahead so
we say how could only one proton
in the nucleus make such a difference
because you're comparing what was to the
left of it and to the right of it
on the periodic table and the periodic
table is an ascension
of proton count in the nucleus
of atoms that's what that is and you go
from hydrogen
at number one one proton up to
uranium 92 protons and then the
elements we create in the lab goes up to
i forgot what they're up to
120 something like that so wow
so it turns out remarkably and we didn't
really understand this until
quantum physics in the 1920s which gave
us an understanding
of how it is that you have periodicity
in the properties of elements
on the table okay so you have to
certainly going to start a band called
periodicity
periodicity because i've never heard
that word before until periodicity you
never heard that okay
periodicity so what we learned from
applying quantum physics to the periodic
table is
that vertically on the table
elements have properties chemical
properties
similar to each other so where you find
carbon for example you look
directly what's directly below it it's
silicon
and so we're carbon based life so
everyone is eagerly looking for silicon
based life
if carbon can make life in all these
molecules that comprise life as we know
it
silicon sitting right below it makes the
same families of molecules
as carbon does and so
so elements in vertical columns we've
learned how and why that's so
from quantum physics has similar
chemical properties
but the prop but the melting point is
not a chemical property
it's actually intrinsic to the element
itself and so
so what happens when you change it then
the charge changes
in the nucleus of the atom and that
changes the electron orbitals
in response to it not orbits but
orbitals we call them inspired by the
orbits of planets by the way
because we thought maybe you have solar
system with the sun in the middle
and planets in orbit around it as we
start poking the atom
it's got a nucleus it's got electrons
maybe it's the same thing
but just little right and it's not
whole other laws of physics apply there
and that's the realm of quantum physics
so point is uh mercury melts
at about 40 degrees below zero and so
it's liquid that
all degrees above that until it
evaporates
and that that's a unique property so
many elements on the periodic table have
unique properties relative to everything
around them
that it's one of the reasons to
celebrate that it exists at
all and it's a testament to the genius
of chemists and physicists
who go into those elements and say this
has this property
so i'm going to do this other thing with
it this conducts electricity this does
not conduct electricity
this is brittle this is flexible
this is gaseous this is liquid and so
we've
we've gone all into the periodic table
and basically
constructed civilization based on it
so i don't have a good answer for you
because i don't know what to tell you
about why that's liquid and nothing
around it is left to right or up or down
but i can tell you being liquid is not
the most
it's not the most different thing about
an element
that you can find among elements on the
periodic table
wow okay um so and by the way
if we lived in the world there was 50
below zero right
you wouldn't be asking this question
would be solid like every other element
okay we can go to a warmer environments
and
you'd find some things that then become
liquid
and you might be asking that about those
other elements
so the fact that we are okay in these
quote room temperatures has consequences
for which elements on the periodic table
are solid liquid or gas
wow that's right so that's me dancing
around the fact that i don't actually
know the answer to that question
okay so for somebody who i'd hate to
know what if you knew the answer
god you'd be here till next year if you
actually knew the answer
what i'll do is i'll do some homework on
it and i'll come back and see
what i can tell about the the
relationship of one
mercury atom to another and why it is
that
at this temperature unlike every other
metal on the periodic table
that they don't make a solid lattice
i'll find out and i'll get back to it
all right well thanks taracina for
giving dr tyson some homework
okay all right let's uh here we go this
is
uh oh by the way there's an element and
i forgot which element forgive me
i'll dig it up the next time i return
there's an in in the uk
uh the ambient indoor temperature lab
temperature
is slightly lower than in the united
states or in germany or in france
and so when the uk folks made their
periodic table
there's an element that they listed as
liquid but in the united states and
france and
everywhere else it was listed as um i'm
sorry listed as solid but for everybody
else it was liquid
wow and yeah so that's from a slight
variation in the lab
yeah just because the ambient lab
temperature in england is about you know
five
degrees cooler than the ambient lab
temperature in
other sort of industrialized states at
the time
so the point is if you want to think of
the periodic table as some
fundamental truth about the universe
then you should
not be distracting yourself with what
temperature it melts
because that can depend not only on the
individual pro whether it's sorry
if you if you want to think of the
periodic table as some deep fundamental
truth about the universe
then you should not be distracting
yourself about whether it's solid liquid
or gas
at your laboratory temperature because
the universe
doesn't give a rat's ass about your
laboratory temperature
that's not a fundamental truth about the
element whether it's liquid in your lab
yeah there you go don't you know who i
am i'm the universe
thank you you want me to think what
you're
what you're saying you're cold you need
a sweater
i'm the universe are you kidding that's
right yeah so
uh yeah so you think this is called i'm
at an absolute zero oh
well a couple grease above it and you
know
and you know the methane that comes out
of your stove if you use a gas stove
right um on earth that's gaseous you go
to saturn's moon
titan right it has the right combination
of temperature and air pressure
to liquefy methane
methane sounds like a dream
and the water it is so cold that the
water has frozen
so solid that it's basically the bedrock
on the planet
they're boulders and it's just ice but
that those are the rocks
and think about it inside a volcano what
happens to rock
it melts it melts so if if we're in an
environment that's as hot as a volcano
you would not think of rocks as anything
solid you'd say oh that's a liquid let's
take a bath
and so so these conditions that you
happen to
live in are not themselves fundamental
to to what's going on on the periodic
table wow
there you go all right taracina we got
more out of that than i ever thought for
somebody who said that i don't know
[Laughter]
only physicists and astrophysicists
answer questions that they don't know
for
six minutes
all right here we go here we go this is
jordan bellaconus
he says hey boy wait wait one other
thing okay
there are places on mars where the
temperature
and the air pressure the atmospheric
pressure are
just right that water if you live there
water would freeze
melt and boil all at the same time
um what
you can have you can have a a bowl of
water
with ice cubes in it and the water is
boiling
and that's stable that's that's pretty
okay i don't i was going to say that's
hot but it's not so
it's not that's it's and i was going to
say it's cool but it's
okay that's hot and cool and that's
everything that's everything at the same
time it's good
it's not tepid right so that it's called
a triple point
and water has a triple point of
atmospheric pressure
and temperature where all states three
states of matter
can co-exist happily and so yeah
that's why you can say water is liquid
no water is only liquid when you
make it a liquid okay right otherwise
it's solid or gaseous
all right cool there you go all right
all right jordan bell conus
uh yep he says hey dr tyson
and chuck what's happening i never have
been able to understand the thought of
terraforming mars considering
listen here's the real thing it's a dead
planet
with no magnetic field it seems solar
wind and extreme
uv would strip the atmosphere and kill
any life
anyway can you please help explain
how this would ever work okay
so so he's he's two steps ahead of
someone who might have
only just now heard of terraforming so
terraforming is you take a dead planet
and then you you you seed the
the atmosphere with with aerosols or you
you introduce microbes that will thrive
on the carbon dioxide
and might output oxygen and then you
step back and let it run its thing if
you put in the right
cocktail and then out comes an arable
green planet that you've just
terraformed that's not
an impossible dream okay it's not i mean
earth
was terraformed early on by earth itself
right
so the question is can you do it like
fast if you have to leave earth
you gotta find another place and they
did in the one star trek movie
they did in the movie yes yes it was the
genesis movie the genesis that's what it
was called the genesis project right
they took some pod or something and sent
it down and right uh
the pod was somebody's
dead body that then came back to life oh
spock yeah
yeah yeah cool okay so you're worried
the the the who is this now jake this is
um
jordan jordan says uh yeah so jordan is
worried that because
mars does not have a magnetic field
which would then shield it from
a solar wind whose energy can break
apart
molecules or have ozone that would
protect it from ultraviolet
all of these without these protections
life on earth we don't
know how you would sustain it okay
that's fine
consider that if you're living
underground none of that matters
oh okay you go
shield yourself from the sun none of
that matters martian morlocks
yeah martian morlocks that's what we got
so that first of all you can just shield
yourself from it second
if we have the power of geoengineering
right to turn
mars into an arable place i don't see
why we couldn't figure out some way to
deflect the solar wind
or to block out uv i'm not worried
that's like an engineering challenge and
engineers tend to solve problems when
given the task
and so i'm not i'm not worried about
that it's the rest that is
way more complex we know how to block uv
we know how to block the solar wind we
don't know how to
how to send in microbes and come back 10
years later and
and have a forest we just don't know how
to do that that's where the challenges
are right now
gotcha gotcha so we got the sunscreen
covered
so exactly that that part's good
yeah yeah we're good we we good all
right okay well there you go jordan i
mean at least you're thinking two steps
ahead of anybody else who's
exactly terraforming good for you all
right here we go
oh by the way if you can if you can if
you have good geo engineering
you might find a way to stir up the
martian core
so that it can then generate another
magnetic field
i mean what's stopping us right yeah we
the earth gets its
magnetic field from our iron core the
iron cord is spinning inside of us
yeah yeah inside of that is has this
moving iron which is conductive
and whenever conductive moving material
it can generate currents and currents
generate
magnetic fields so mars that's all
stopped
long ago but why not if we can control
planets
go stir it up again right see mars
that's why nobody finds you attractive
because you want to have a magnetic
field just don't don't
i just made that up come on man okay all
right you don't have to test it on this
[Laughter]
go to program mic night and see how
people do
damn oh my god oh
boy that was damn good though
oh my goodness yeah chuck is wiping away
his tears
oh man cause you got me with that one
man
you ain't got to test it out here
test it out on my show oh
man i need some visine now soon
all right here we go we gotta take a
quick break oh okay all right we're
gonna come back to segment number three
of star talk cosmic aquarius grab bag be
there
all right we're back uh star talk cosmic
queries
uh chuck you're tweeting at chuck nice
comic yes thank you sir that's correct
i do indeed follow you i don't follow
many things i follow you just let you
know well that's great i followed you
first
so it's not a competition i can't top
that sorry yeah there you go
all right what are some other questions
you got for us we've got one segment
left
let's see how many we can squeeze in
let's see what we can do here uh
this is abhinav yadav hello dr tyson and
sir nice i'm excited to be asking my
very first question
now you have spoken about them about
moon disrupting
observation time uh
oh yeah are there places in the solar
system
that are much better for it where this
doesn't exist somewhere we can just send
telescopes and observe love the show
yeah that that's there's a lot going on
in that question so let me just unpack
it
briefly so first of all the full moon at
night
is crazy bright in fact it's something
like
six times brighter than a half moon
because
of the way the laws of reflection work
okay you think it'd only be like twice
as bright it's like
even brighter so on a moonless night
you the unaided eye can see a couple of
thousand stars
if the moon is out you can see a couple
hundred stars so it drops it by a factor
of ten
so if you're trying to see the deep
universe we have what's called dark time
at telescopes
and it's highly competitive to gain
access to a telescope while the moon is
not up
okay it's called dark time and then
people who are on the
brink of the detection of things will
ask for dark time
so then we learned well why be on earth
at all
why okay but if you go into orbit
the moon is still there okay now the sky
is not as bright but it's still
kind of you don't want to look near the
moon you have scattered light
uh into your telescope beam so
how about a million miles on the other
side of the moon
how about that well that's where the
james webb space telescope is going oh
cool
yeah so it's far away from earth and
from the moon
and so yeah we're doing our darndest to
get rid of the
interference that we're now experiencing
but let me stay at it there's radio
interference and we have
radio wave telescopes right so what are
we going to do about that
there's all this talk whole conference
is given unto putting radio telescopes
on the far side of the moon wow because
the
moon only shows one face so if you're on
the far side you will never
see earth ever right okay so that famous
photo of earthrise over the moon
by apollo 8 okay earth doesn't rise on
the moon
right it never does it's either always
there
or never there because you're either on
the side of the moon that faces earth
or the side of the earth the moon that
faces
elsewhere and so the reason why that's
called earth rises because they were
orbiting the moon and when you're
orbiting then the sky moves
rises and sets and so they caught the
rising earth
on the lunar landscape so it's it's
legitimately earth rising it's just
highly misleading
right that's all it's like moon haiti
and moon dominican republic
so it's just same island just one side
is haiti and the other side of the
american republic
is that really the first i'm talking the
universe here and you're talking
geopolitics
man i need a vacation i'm really just
thinking about tropical
places that's right but they are the
same island somebody just cut a line
right down
that's it right all right well so uh
yeah so we are thinking about that and
it is a big problem and so wherever
the electromagnetic spectrum is noisiest
we try to do our darndest to avoid it
and sometimes it means going into space
to the far side of the moon and even
into
deep space itself wow cool man
yeah yeah all right so okay now what
what probe just got out of our solar
system
and will we would be able to receive so
i'm just thinking about telescopes
oh you're talking about voyager voyager
so
will we be able to get retrieve any
information from that
we have what's called a senior review of
projects that are growing long of tooth
that have been going for a while even if
they're giving
trickles of data you say to yourself it
costs this much
what is the incremental knowledge we're
gleaning about our state of the universe
relative to this new project that is
looking for
seed funding to discover something new
and exciting and so sometimes you gotta
turn off the switch
voyager we turn off the switch after it
exited
the influence of the sun there's
everyone thinking oh the solar system
ends at pluto
no solar system keeps going right all
right and one way to think about it is
uh as long as you're near enough to the
sun to
feel its sort of magnetic field and
other effects you say i'm part of the
solar system
right but the galaxy has a magnetic
field also right
so if you start getting farther and
farther away from the sun
the strength of the sun's magnetic field
drops and the strength
relative to the strength of the galactic
magnetic field
you reach a point oh by the way it's not
just magnetic field but the particle
stream
emanating from the sun relative to the
ambient particle stream in the galaxy
you reach a point where you can no
longer tell the difference between those
two
bada bing you've left the solar system
cool
yeah all right that's how you think
about that all right that's how you
think about it all right cool
and since we're talking telescopes here
when you talk about
observation time earlier
if you're an important are you asking a
question now no
this is you know this is still um
uh abhinav yeah okay i was just you know
because
you gotta become a patreon member if
you're gonna ask me a question that's
all i'm just checking
go on because you you got all the data
there so yeah i also
i'm also lying but hey
no here's what i would know if you're an
important scientist do you get
bumped up in your uh your request for
observation time
are they just like jimmy please you're
really that research get out of here
like
yeah your seniority has nothing to do
with it
that's how brilliant is your idea and
that's why on our research papers
we don't put their your earned degrees
next to your name
all right so a an undergraduate you know
one of these sort of precocious research
interested graduate students
could have their name right next to
someone who's highly senior or even a
nobel laureate
no degrees are put there no no such
distinctions are made
oh my god it's the masked physicist
instead of the masked singer mass
physicist
yeah so we don't and i think that's one
of the um
that's an important feature of the
entire enterprise now
if you have an idea that's a little
crazy that it's not getting past any
reviews
the director of the telescope has what's
called directors discretionary
time and they can say you know i want to
give this this a shot
oh wow and they can grant the time and
it won't have to go through the
the peer review to be given the time oh
but ultimately the research you do
based on it would have to be peer
reviewed if you're going to publish it
okay
that's a great system by the way it is
it is and by the way the very famous
hubble deep field do you know that
picture that has just
galaxies yes and there's a couple of
stars but everything you might think is
a star is an entire galaxy yeah
that was allocated on director's
discretion every time
okay and it became one of the most
significant images ever taken by the
telescope
and you know who received that
discretionary that directed this
question every time
no the director he gave it to himself
no yes get out yes
oh that's tremendous yes
is that badass he was like you know what
man that's gangster
you know i want to look out into nothing
and there's nothing you could you can't
why would you point this to the
telescope that way there's nothing there
because i can all right i'm the director
i'm the hdic the head
director in charge beyonc okay
so the funny thing is you you're
absolutely right the hubble deep field
was a spot on the sky that was the least
interesting
spot you can possibly find there were no
interesting stars
no previously discovered interesting
galaxies black holes right
nothing and he says let me take the most
potent
powerful telescope in the world and aim
it there and
hang there and let those meagre photons
accumulate and let's see what's lurking
in the dark
thus was born the hubble d field it may
have been the most
significant uh image taken by the
telescope itself
and so we we allow for that kind of
creative thinking that might not
otherwise get through
that's by the way what a great story
i love my people i mean seriously that's
probably equally as exciting as the
discovery itself
all right uh this is dale uh
buen and dale says hey neil photons
don't experience
time they don't ever decay would
they decay wait a minute would
they decay if they did experience time
yeah so decay means you are this
this form of matter in one moment and
later on you're a different form of
matter
and you can time that out and there's
usually some variance there but there's
a very
tight average that we give for like it's
called the half-life
of for example carbon-14 any radioactive
element has a half-life
well if all the atoms know that they're
supposed to convert within some
statistical time frame
then they must have a measure of time
there must be some kind of clock
going on within them all right photons
moving at the speed of light time stops
for them
so if you have no measure of time then
you cannot know
to turn into anything else later in life
because there is no later
if photons did happen to experience time
it means they would not be going at the
speed of light
okay and they would not be pure energy
as they currently are
and then they would have the ability to
transform into another kind of particle
wow yeah that is so trippy
my god that is so trippy okay because
they would know how to keep time
and if you know how to keep time you
would have some clock and you say
you know in one year five years three
seconds a tenth of a second
i'm going to turn into another particle
now just because you have a clock
doesn't mean you will turn into another
particle
the other conditions have to be right
but if you don't have a clock there's no
reason or understanding we possibly have
for why you would change
okay so photons are super gangsta
so it means the photon
that we detect here that was emitted in
the early universe shortly after the big
bang
uh as far as it's concerned it's still
very big
hey let me tell you something man i'm a
photon i don't ride or die
i ride and die i take the ride always
dying
at the same time so it gets so it is
detected in the same instant
that it is emitted right according to
the photon itself so that's amazing
fascinating so life is a photon
is it like you said it's a trippy thing
wow
yeah god i love science yeah i mean that
is just amazing
okay let's get another one in here yeah
maybe slip in another one okay this is
nicholas uh lenson
nicholas says hey neil hey chuck given
that the black holes lose mass slowly
but thoroughly
until they no longer exist would there
be a point in time
where the mass of the black hole is no
longer sufficient
to trap light so
the surface of the black hole would
become
visible and what would that look like
so wait a minute did this guy just
discover a way to look inside of a black
hole
any amount of mass you can calculate how
small it would have to be how compressed
would it have to be
for it to become a black hole so if you
wanted earth to become a black hole
you'd have to shrink it down to like the
size of a plum
last i did the math on that so if you
manage to do that
bada bing you have an earth black hole
the point is
a lower mass black hole is smaller than
a higher mass black hole
if a black hole begins losing mass
it gets smaller and becomes the black
hole size
appropriate for the amount of mass it
has got
so it's stuck being always going to be
a black hole correct no matter what the
mass is
now that it has collapsed into a black
hole it can't be
anything else so it continues to lose
that mass
it will always maintain the properties
of a black hole
because it can't be anything else as it
shrinks down that's right now if for
some magic force of nature the black
hole evaporates according to hawking
radiation which
which your guy clearly knows about and
somehow
did not get smaller there would be a
point where the
density would no longer allow it to be a
black hole because it's about the
density it's not about the mass right
density
and then the black hole would slowly
reveal itself
as a solid object ah look at that
so it was a great question and if one
day we could manipulate the laws of
physics
then we could reach into a black hole
somehow prop up
its its shape so that as it got
less and less mass the density would
drop and then we could reveal what's
inside but then
at that point you're no longer looking
inside a black hole are you you're just
looking at a regular object right right
because you really need that mass
down to that small density in order for
it to be a black hole
and you know what happens as the black
hole continues to evaporate
the energy range that gets emitted
becomes higher and higher and higher
so large black holes are emitting like
radio waves and
smaller black holes will emit visible
light the tiniest of black holes
will emit gamma rays okay and it has to
do with the size of the black hole
whether the wave
that it emits can fit inside the black
hole or not
that's the quantum physics of it hawking
worked all this out point is
as it gets smaller and smaller smaller
and smaller the
very last bit oh by the way the as it
gets smaller the rate at which it gives
off energy increases
gotcha okay so this becomes a runaway
process where it gets smaller and
smaller faster and faster and faster
and the very last moment it happens
catastrophically
and you get a little burst of gamma rays
wow
so the original hawking radiation paper
prompted people to look for little
bursts of gamma rays
like in the universe which could signal
black holes dying having completely
evaporated that is amazing
yeah okay now we do see bristol gamma
rays but they don't match the spectrum
of
dying black hole but but there it is wow
this is our universe we all live in it's
a beautiful place all right chuck that
was fun
so this is another star talk cosmic
queries it's
uh uh just questions from patreon
members it was a
grab bag and i i want to go back to
galactic gumbo
yeah i don't want to hear you imitate
[Laughter]
we'll we'll figure it out on the next on
the next time out all right
dude good to have you always always a
pleasure all right this has been stark
talk
cosmic queries as always neil degrasse
tyson here
bidding you to keep looking up
[Music]
you